I recommend doing parasite protocols regularly, whether you have symptoms or not, and if so,
how often? Is it beneficial to let the body rest and recuperate after a certain amount of time
if there are symptoms of die-offs once you are doing a parasite cleanse? Is there a particular type
of protocol that you would recommend, herbal parasites, supplements, or parasite medications?
What's the law? There's a lot of questions there. Do you want to recommend doing a parasite
cleanse on a regular basis? Yeah, I do. I personally do, but remember there's different types
of parasites. So there's intestinal parasites. There's parasites that could go systemic. There's parasites
that are not truly parasites, but they're bacteria that are basically parasitic,
and so they need to be treated a little bit differently. Personally, I use our private label product
called Paraclear because it has things in there that will help with intestinal parasites and worms
and things in there that will help with bacteria, bacterial type parasitic things like H. Pylori,
which is a bacterial infection, but kind of acts like a parasite because it can be very long term
that you could have it for years and spread it like crazy and just get it back again and it could
cause a whole lot of ill health. That's why I like Paraclear because it has the things in there that will
help with that. So there are other parasite programs out there. We have some products from
cell core. They have a parasite protocol bundle with different herbs in it in each supplement and you
take these three or four supplements and you go through a month of this and that could be a nice
cleanse. The reason why I personally like the Paraclear is because there's a
no, you have to take more, if you take same amount of pills, they're all in one bottle. So
you're getting it all in one bottle. You might, if you feel like you have parasites, like when I take
Paraclear, I'm out of fact, I just did this with my wife just last week for about a week. I took
anywhere between nine and 12 capsules a day. I only did it for like three or four days. I think I skipped
a day because I'm not very good at taking supplements sometimes. I forgot. I got busy but I think it
really does help clear any parasites, any bacteria. And I always have the fear of H. Pylori when
you are the understanding. Pylori, I think you should treat it on a regular basis. Do we get,
you know, three or four days, once three months, I think is extremely beneficial. Second part of
this question should you use a bite? Would you have to worry about die-offs when you're doing a parasite
cleanse? So if you're doing a parasite cleanse that's dealing with parasites that are in your gut or
in your liver, like liver flukes, no, you don't really have to worry about die-offs at all. You're
going to expel that. Again, you've got to make sure all your phases of detoxification are open.
If you're constipated, you're only having available every three days. You've got to deal with that
before you think about doing a parasite cleanse. But if you're moving your balls at least once, twice a
day, no, you shouldn't have any issue with die-offs. If you feel like you're getting, if you do a parasite
cleanse, like using a product like Paracler that has burberry in it and garlic in it, and you're
getting herximer type reactions, then you need to rethink what you possibly have going on. So the
only thing that's going to truly give you a herximer type reaction is, if you're dealing with a
gram-negative bacteria, because they have lipopolysaccharides in their cell membrane,
when they die, that's going to stimulate any response. You're going to feel yucky because you're
just producing 2-odd endotoxins. And that is in the blood that's not in the gut. So using a binder
can be helpful no matter what you're dealing with. So adding a binder to your protocol, taking that
out of empty stomach can be helpful. But if you're starting to get herximer reactions, you need to
rethink really what it is that you could be killing with that. Or if you have to be careful while
you're doing something like that too, if you're taking something with garlic in it, which is something
that you'd use typically for H. Pylora and for parasites, that's going to be an immune stimulant.
And you do have to be aware of that if you know you have an autoimmune disease.
That's why I think if you know you have an autoimmune disease, let's say if you have Hashimoto's,
and you think you have parasites doing the short-term parasite cleanse like three or four days out
of the month are actually much healthier for you. If you do a month-long parasite protocol that has
immune stimulants in it, and you already know you have an autoimmune disease, like you already
worked diagnosed with thyroid antibodies. So you have Hashimoto's, you're going to make your
thyroid worse during that time. So I wouldn't do that. So remember, if you're going to stimulate
your immune system, you want to do it for a short period of time. If you have autoimmune antibodies,
if you have antibodies to self tissue because you will kill that which you have antibodies against
first, which is, it's not really good in this, it's so be careful of that.